Southeast Asia is often overshadowed by
Europe and Middle East and East Asia's
major powers but the region is of great
importance to the United States today
Southeast Asia is poised to become a
driver of global economic growth which
is crucial at a time when China is
facing growing economic headwinds but
Southeast Asia also faces myriad
security challenges from Chinese
encroachment in the South China Sea to
the scourge of terrorism and insurgency
to non-traditional security threats like
natural disasters and transnational
crime these challenges along with
limited political freedom in a number of
countries to prevent the region from
reaching its full potential to ensure
that it does the United States should
deep an engagement in the region to
dissuade China from future destabilizing
behavior to counter terrorism and
insurgency to promote free-market
principles and to encourage more
resilient and more accountable
governance in doing so the United States
can shape a Southeast Asia that is open
peaceful and prosperous and over the
longer terms freer as well a good result
for Americans and Southeast Asians alike
what do you think about US Southeast
Asian relations let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI